absolute batman but more importantly i
have i just have
energy and no pain in my body so at 54.
yeah i wouldn't yeah if i were you
because you're as much as i'd love to
see you on steroids you don't [ __ ] with
it it's an experiment that i always
anytime somebody asked me out i'm like
have an exit strategy if you're not
committing to this for the rest of your
life that's the problem have an extra
strategy because i've you know
guys that come to me and get on trt or
something and then stop after like three
weeks i'm like what the [ __ ] are you
doing
like you just [ __ ] your endocrine
system up where you have to like you're
not taking the right [ __ ] afterwards now
you're going to be depressed you're
going to lose all the muscle that you oh
it does that to you
oh it's just because it shuts off if you
put in any amount of testosterone in
your body exogenously
your body's going to like oh oh you got
it okay yeah you're not stopped working
that's why guys how does one get off of
it you take
compounds like uh hcc
clomid novadex these things that will
prompt your body
to start making action but if you don't
do that the use doesn't
necessarily fix itself oh [ __ ] guys have
really screwed
themselves up yeah and that's where you
were like like oh i took steroids all
netty
thyroid everything gets kind of thrown
off everything has a
consequence to it so it's just you're
managing these side effects there's a
science to it and if you're getting
involved you should probably
haphazardly and that's that would just
be my recommendation to anybody who's
like
[ __ ] researcher [ __ ] you know
somebody messaged me
like hey ah still so i wanted to work
out more what steroids should i take i'm
like
you're not ready to do that yeah because
you haven't read the first sentence
anywhere and you're using me like google
how
to do that you should write a book
called steroids for dummies
there's so much stupid [ __ ] out there
like especially when i was you know
i would go on bodybuilding.com forums
and then
it was just like trial by error this
guy's like oh i took 500 milligrams of
test this is how i feel
start to see like i guess it's also for
guys a lot of times guys like me if i go
on
the only reason guy like me is going to
go on is he wants to look closer to that
problem is that's gene there's a genetic
you have to be realistic too
because the amount like and you could
even see guys like this guy eric
kanevsky
kind of got famous for like um he put
his cycle online and he was like i take
3 000 milligrams of test energy
2 000 the amount you're going
this is not just like twice what
somebody could take and get results
you're taking oh yeah so this guy
holy [ __ ] he is he's like 24 years old
or something like that
he's only 24. and if you see his before
picks the dude was scary if you could do
erikanewski before and after so that's
not he detailed his cycle
like 20 units of growth hormone a day
300 milligrams
and he looks like [ __ ] on stage that he
will never win a bodybuilding
competition if you look at that picture
he'll win my bodybuilding right
now he looks like a buff dude for like
youtube videos i'm saying not to knock
his
his like uh you know what he did to get
there
but he doesn't have that's only genetics
i'm talking 10 to 20 times the amount
that somebody had genetics could take
and get
great results from right all that stuff
scares me i just want to work out so
that's the route you want to take if you
want to be a wwe guy and you're
skinny or like now he's like a youtuber
and i think he's a good dude i'm just
like
people thought he was like exaggerating
what he took it's like no because
if you don't have the genetics you just
have to keep cranking it and there's
diminishing returns too
you think 20 units of hgh is going to be
better like is twice as good at 10 no
it's about this much better oh yeah
tattooed on his face so is it better to
take steroids younger then
yeah no no here's one element of it well
nice try christian
we see you dog i would think about it
like this if anybody's thinking about
that going have you even come close to
maximizing your genetic potential
which is this logarithmic curve of like
yeah in your first
five years you're probably going to get
most of it and depends on how
long you would want to like eek out you
know another pound of muscle every year
after
certain points get the newbie gains do
as much as you can naturally
learn how to [ __ ] train and if you're
approaching it like
i'm lazy and i don't like lifting but i
want to look good i'm going to take
steroids
wrong answer because it ain't going to
fix anything and you're just going to
[ __ ] yourself up worse
right so to me the the people who are
the best candidates for it it's like you
already lift you already know how to
train you already have a healthy
lifestyle you
are 25 or older or whatever your you
know
30s or 40s and want to start trt because
you've noticed your own
sex drive decline or you're depressed or
something else but you know but
you have to be in a position where you
know how to train you this guy i know
this guy i know helps
the nhl and yeah he's he's really
knowledgeable and he also is a
scientist and he's also a guy who
actually knows
all the details he's got because the
guys he works with are athletes that
can't get
caught and need results right right and
he said that a lot of times with dudes
who have
like low testosterone first thing to
look at is their sleep
how much are they sleeping and also then
he checks their magnesium zinc and
there are certain things where you'd go
and they're off your testosterone yes
yes so you can he brings that back up
yeah that's why oysters
they say because oysters you can eat one
oyster according to don d'agostino who's
uh
at the college of florida and you will
get all your zinc magnesium and all
certain minerals for the week with one
so oysters shellfish are so [ __ ] good
for these they're one of those
remember zma i used to say oh yeah yeah
yeah crazy dreams
yeah right always good sleep what's that
yeah it was the zinc
yeah it's such an interesting world to
me yeah but the sleep things if you do
something dude get on something i'm not
getting on all this stuff tearing that
up a little bit
before i was asleep no i don't want it
impossible to maximize it
you just can't do it you gotta sleep
you're eight hours man yeah
and that says yeah sleep and food it's
like you want to start anabolics
yeah start with the anabolic food and
sleep that you yeah
and then training exactly